President Biden's comments regarding
Russian President Vladimir Putin's
possible use of nuclear weapons is
Raising new concerns about the war in
Ukraine the president warned on Thursday
that he takes Putin's threats seriously
and that the world is closer to
Armageddon this as a counter-offensive
by Ukrainian forces has Russia losing
ground and its military on the run as
Charlie mentioned Christina raffini has
the very latest from the White House
Christina good morning
good morning Dana will President Biden
didn't respond to our shouted questions
about those remarks yesterday as he
boarded Marine one but that same
language is now being used by the
Ukrainian president who said in an
interview he believes Russian officials
are laying the groundwork with the
Russian public for a potential possible
future use of nuclear weapons
I think that it's dangerous even to
speak about it in an interview with the
BBC Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski said he doesn't know if Russia
will use nuclear weapons but he and
President Biden agree on the
consequences I agree it is an Armageddon
it is the risk for the whole planet that
word first uttered this week by
President Biden at a closed-door
Democratic fundraiser in New York where
he said quote I don't think there's any
such thing as the ability to easily use
a tactical nuclear weapon and not end up
with Armageddon the risk of which he
added the world hasn't faced since the
1962 Cuban Missile Crisis Russia has an
estimated one thousand to two thousand
short-range nuclear weapons at storage
sites around the country including one
close to the Ukrainian border
they could be launched from an aircraft
from the sea or from the ground by a
nuclear artillery shell here's one being
tested by the U.S Army in the 1950s this
would be a serious Mistake by Putin but
he needs to know that in advance we can
stop it from happening in the first
place
Congressman Mike McCall is the top
Republican on the house Foreign Affairs
committee we see any indication from the
intelligence community that he is taking
steps forward to to launch a nuclear
threat into Ukraine I think we need to
show that to the world
the White House says President Biden's
comments were not prompted by any
specific evidence a White House official
tells us just a growing concern about
Putin's rhetoric which that individual
called quote Reckless and irresponsible
now in that same interview president
zielinski was asked if Ukraine wins the
war does he think Putin survives after
pausing for a second he said quote I
don't care Dana
I'll take it thank you Christina